what's up patreon community it's Greg
Alva here Humphry over here we're going
to do another moving into the week for
you guys this week May 13th through the
20th only got a few stories when I say
just a small handful with stories only
do have a small handful here we're going
to kick off the first story this first
one will be going up on YouTube because
so many people wanted us to talk about
it but the other three stories are just
for the patron community this is
cluesive commentary on the other one but
here we go for the Tom Hardy one Tom
Hardy he's going to lead venom is going
to play Eddie Brock is going to play
Eddie Brock in Ruben flashes then a
movie with I don't know don't question
me on my method of madness and germs
stop okay only way you edited these damn
yeah off to a weird start John I got the
bed very late I got today like 9:00 in
the morning
and he got to bed I don't know why but
you had to get up a lot earlier than
main but you got we got it we got and I
get up and drive an hour yeah you have
to get up drive very far but anyway
let's talk about this Tom Hardy to leave
them when I first heard of the venom
movie announcement I thought why why are
you doing why is Sony doing its own
separate venom entry it seems like it
would be weird to create a spider-man
universe it is no Spidey and you know
even if they're comic books based on
venom like most people know that
character for being spider-man villain
well this whole origin deals with
spider-man higher origin deals with an
entire process of spider-man you know as
accurately portrayed by Topher Grace and
Sam Raimi spider-man 3 completely
accurately all that muscle he put on
yeah Eddie Brock he didn't play Topher
Grace at all he played the Eddie Brock
we all knew and loved yeah the comics
totally you will love imposing
photography yeah he wasn't sarcastic guy
that we saw from that 70s show and I was
like I can't get any better than Jackie
maybe Tom Hardy could do a good job
that's a big Navy but that's not gonna
happen
oh wait look at that yeah uh well I
don't I I still think it's a weird idea
however I've thought about it a little
bit more spider-man homecoming it's
specifically in the high school years
now they could readjust it where because
we know like what would its fundamental
one do he's in high school for a little
bit then he goes red joey graduate OHS
did come and it made his spine around
one supposed to stay in high school and
in part two he graduates and he didn't
get into the Daily Bugle yet but they
were headed that direction it was gonna
happen but he supposed to put the whole
pull the whole interaction with Peter
Parker and Eddie Brock afford a bracket
see what it goes symbiont them for it
gets accepted with the simia yeah that's
all happens with Peter Parker's an adult
so when I thought about that then it
started making a little more sense to me
because okay you got the spider-man
homecoming franchise in the MCU where he
where's Peter Parker specifically in
high school and this could take place so
maybe they could do to one a few things
I think they they could have it be in
this still within the MCU which I know
they said they're not doing but they
could do that word sold an MCU just a
little bit later where it's you know
down the road and where Peter Parker at
this point in the timeline he is an
adult he's not he's not in high school
anymore because it would make sense for
the timeline of the venom origin story
well the Infinity wars are going to be
like his World War two and it is going
to get frozen for a long time yeah I'm
gonna wake up in the future we talk hard
yeah it could be that or they could they
could just do their own separate venom
movie i I guess things like what they
have to do here like I guess it could
work
there are venom cut like like is the
same breath as I used it before like
there are venom comics I know that there
is a series dedicated to venom so
there's like if there's stuff to draw
from I don't know what the I have no
idea what to expect that is weird news
because we were listening to some news
earlier and they said like Tom Hardy at
least got everyone interested and I
think that's absolutely like hearing Tom
Hardy wants to do this
I'll definitely
take a look at he's just an actor but he
is really max enter an actor and we sure
has a spotty record ruben fleischer has
a very sloppy track record yeah it feels
declined he did Zombieland and everyone
loved it they had 30 minutes or less
which was like a decent comedy I thought
it was funny yeah it's kind of what I
heard Lee do you laugh it's funny
something special and they need a
gangster squad which has bomb ass
trailer but it'll be really really bad
yeah not even and Emily was filled with
great actors yeah but no one could save
that movie yeah so I mean just could you
get Tom Hardy as the lead it's like
don't get me wrong
Tom Hardy as venom sounds like a great
choice
Tom Hardy is like the go-to actor it's
like either Tom Hardy or hit yourself
over black actors but it's appear yeah
and it's here go to actors or people are
like we should reboot Wolverine to Oh
Lord you should be blood telemarketer
yourself oh who you should be the nude
and Metal Gear Solid so what is the
summer is the only way an actor you need
to sell the daily black yeah so it's
cool that they landed Tom Hardy for this
what and it does make me wonder cuz he
doesn't seem like he just takes any job
you know like that maybe I feel like he
could bring something good to this it
was originally cast as boomerang and
Suicide Squad that is sure good see
that's a role it's like I don't know how
I feel a lot in leading one of these
maybe that's it there's something that's
weird about his casting to me because
it's the first time I feel like I
wouldn't be maybe distracted by his
presence yeah
whereas like a more sign character like
boomerang is like I'm sure you have free
rein to kind of do it and I just don't
know what Sony is doing we need because
I mean the man this whole deal with the
MCU and Marvel or their life we need
your help and then they got the help and
now that it's
spider-man's like hot again and everyone
has faith and spider-man again they're
like woo milk a little more money for so
outside of the MCU absolutely they just
want kept working together whenever
profits they split what could probably
be enough to compensate for whatever
solo franchise films are making which is
in their own Spidy world outside or
spider-man day and I'm teasing every
major a lot of the major studios have
their you know superhero machines and
Sony is I get it like they're not going
to go
they're not gonna like that's the
problem though it's like as a business
moves they they have to use all this
stuff they have the right to because
this is the opportunity yeah but at the
same time yeah I just don't I don't know
how their cinematic universe is gonna
really just come together I'm totally
happy to be surprised but I hope they
have a condition from everything I've
heard that this summer they can even use
spider-man yeah I would believe that you
know if they can't use spider-man what's
the point of doing this separate
spider-man universe without a spider-man
I mean if they can get like a Miles
Morales in there but then it was origin
Taylor deals with Peter Parker
specifically will loophole that can
actually they could be a cool loophole
but like I said I mean this spider-man
itself probably makes it problematic I
feel like you can't do a straight-up
venom origin tale without playing
without spider-man you gotta at least
have him in the shadows or
you got it you gotta be aware that he
exists within the universe alike are the
universe isn't yet a subdued the
shattered the world listed no value the
twine yeah yeah oh yeah you see a smart
way to hit that then you know Andrew
Fletcher though he doesn't seem like the
kind of director to me who seems like
the right fit for a venom film to begin
with
oh well yeah and this is a whole lot of
this is odd information and get this
going
you know cuz because we have no idea
what the plot line is we have no idea
what that hone is going to be like and
this this news just makes me wonder it's
got me scratching my head and like kind
of worried but interested
I mean this is one of those things where
I'm going to see it no matter what
this isn't maybe to go hell yeah yeah
even if it gets like a ten percent on
Rotten Tomatoes
yeah I'm going to watch it yeah yeah
definitely yeah it's one of those it's
one of those things being greenlit that
it's guaranteed to have some people like
us at least to namma it's like there to
be a lot of us or phenomenon but it's
guaranteed to have to sell some tickets
but I don't know even though the whole
announcement sounds confusing they could
pull it off there has to be a way where
they I mean they must have something in
mind where they thought about all the
concerns that people like you and I and
everyone else on the Internet is having
with this just sounds very confusing and
for the 3po who or don't follow movie
news are probably going to be especially
confused because you got to step outside
of the bubble that we live in when it
comes to keeping up to date with all the
movie news and all of the comic-book
connections because I've met people who
think x-men is part of the Marvel
Universe
yeah and I don't blame them because they
don't follow the they see the marble
logo at the beginning at the Goblet you
don't love it under the same umbrella
every x-men's over at five and then you
know you've got all the spider-man
something Sony like it is yeah this
makes it even more confusing honestly
there's a lot of people then I know the
comic book fan no venom but I'm sure
there are a lot of people out there who
they see that they'll be like what is it
yeah especially you can't referee by the
spider-man three was a huge film it's so
made like a lot of money so a lot of
people are oh it's a while ago since
spider-man Authority you know it's quick
computers the spider-man 3 came out and
so if you're if you don't if you don't
watch the 90s cartoon or any of the
cartoons or if you don't follow the
comics then you're probably going to be
very confused you might only have a
vague knowledge of who this character at
all and you probably might be wondering
where spider-man is if people might go
yep people might actually go into this
movie they can oh it's part of the MC
you learn spider-man universe and you
know the North confusing bars is
probably going to be a horrible logo
that's laptop before this were to be
replaced a which is just going to
confuse everyone else the thing I am
interested for is is I think
optimistically if they they're taking
advantage of a different kind of
character venom is a villain I've not
really read a bunch of his solo comics
so I don't know exactly what the
dynamics are there he's like yeah some
kind of dark hue or not but but this is
this is another cool opportunity like
like Suicide Squad was kind of an
opportunity that they miss you know to
center something around it darker more
villainous character I think that can be
an edge if they really go all Eddie
totally on that you know well the thing
though is I don't I don't know who this
comes going to satisfy me neither
because this isn't the venom movie we
all wanted it just doesn't sound like it
the circuit and I was like we all wanted
a Tom Hardy to play a venom that sounds
great that sounds like I can go on and
on all day know why Tom Hardy they're
the perfect person to play Eddie Brock
in it's like do we really need to yell
no no they don't know at all or they can
pull it off there's no speculating you
need to do is just like somewhere is
great good at making mannerisms and II
know he looks like Tom Hardy he oughta
just disappeared yeah any computer who
could give you action he could change up
its physicality your fat buff skin who
doesn't matter what that buff skinny fat
but yeah he can do it all but when I
hear the director I hear venom movie
that's going to be separate from the MCU
which see you like that's why I brought
up in the beginning that I feel like
that's where it could kind of work where
I I feel like why not just say you're
connected to the MCU still just at a
little later timeframe where this is
when spider-man's an adult or Peter
Parker's an adult and he's working at
the Daily Bugle because that would makes
sense in terms of this but the venom
sorta we all wanted was the perfect
villain for spider-man yeah I'm sorry we
wanted all these years
that's what spider-man 3 got his hopeful
for and let us down on it all we want it
was venom to be this do that story
justices said
afterthought yeah instead of doing your
own we're trying to get more money yeah
milk it because it still got a little
bit of our own rights of it are clear
are you guys ready graphically how Mike
uses this venom idea would probably do
better if you shared it with the MCU and
you can probably make even more money so
here to be at the split profit that
split will probably equate to more than
whatever they're trying to make here and
it could take a last more long term to
this seems like such a short term
maneuver to me and it's one of those
things where I think I think people have
a right to be concerned and feel worried
and kind of complain a little bit
because this is far from what we really
wanted it to be I guess I mean the other
thing too is like I like I said before
we've talked a lot about it and it is
only it's just two names so like a lot
more yeah I'll have a lot more to say
once I actually see like a clip or some
Sony has nothing to instill fate mmm
everything is dead so when I'm thinking
about the hierarchy of these studios you
know when it comes to Marvel usually I'm
like okay this will probably be at least
yeah you know fine so I don't have a lot
to worry about they've got a good track
record
Fox is like my second place where I'm
like yeah I don't really like Apocalypse
but you know I like a lot of the things
that you do anything for everything
origins there's a Logan Sony is like the
third tier of my totem pole where I'm
like you [ __ ] up a lot you messed up a
lot of things since spider-man 2 like
sure it's better everyone's doing that
everything else from there isn't
problematic and then at the bottom you
got the DS yeah you yeah it just seems
like another Sony trying to milk money
maneuver yeah like I'll believe this is
a good idea when you've shown me it's a
good idea yeah
right now you have my curiosity you
still need to get my attention
yeah I I don't know I I guess there's
systems and now I'm not actually wanted
like will venom ever appear in the MCU
one day in like a hundred years anything
it has like because the beard roots of
it's one thing to have to quicksilver's
but they're both just supporting
characters
Net Worth franchises like we canna
budget yeah and they're very different
you know you have very different
quicksilver's and different iterations
it's like with venom both sexes yeah
both sexy but with venom Manny and I'm
like that's all like the MCU would be
the place to correct whatever venomous
their days yeah 11 Tom Hardy as venom
would be a lot more exciting to me in
the MCU context not yeah like I'm
excited to see him do it I'm curious
about what he's gonna do like that's
cool I'm excited for that but the rest
of it I'm like what's he gonna do on his
own what's he gonna do is Owen just go
happen I would have been fine if it was
like you get a solo venom movie with Tom
Hardy but you know you'll also get one
where he's going up against spider-man
or vice-versa where you get venom as a
villain and then you're getting a solo
venom movie this was the last thing I
actually wanted for them to do with them
yes I'm conflicted Bob like part of me
is like this could be kind I don't know
all right well we're going to move on to
the next story but I will do it quickly
I'll show up for the YouTube video yes
you can subscribe to the real rejects
rate we're right now there's actually a
video we're filming the audio of this is
going up on YouTube as you've been
listened to it thus far we're going to
be talking a few more stories up on our
patreon so you can go there check it out
if you want to hear the rest of our
movie news of the week so catch you all
later